oh yeah when i was on the camp the run
was pretty much saturn in the series and
back
the canterbury i haven't thought about
that in a while
me neither
she fed the firing solution in again the
moment of sickening spin the bang of the
rail gun the crack of the couch taking
her in but the pellet did it again it
dodged the same way it was a pattern and
patterns were gaps in the armor she
could fit a knife in there hey guys pete
here this is my breakdown for the
expanse season six episode three number
three of six so we are at the halfway
point of the season force projection saw
the return of the inners to series
station the return of some characters we
haven't seen since season three and the
rossi and crew overcoming tremendous
odds in battle to get the best of the
free navy take out marco anaros and
bring it into the war that has been
gripping the soul system of course those
last bits didn't happen in the episode
but i will be talking about everything
else that did after this quick spoiler
warning if you're not caught up with the
expanse through the third episode of the
sixth and final season then this video
won't be for you and with that out of
the way let's get into it
as all the episodes of this season do
episode 3 opens on laconia we see a
close-up look at the orbital platforms
for the first time and see a drop
shuttle returning to the planet there's
a classroom scene with the martian
soldier talking to the kids he makes the
distinction that there was a survey
group already there cara's family was a
part of this and that he's from a group
from mars that came after
the martian breakaway fleet he tells the
children the people who've been there
longer can help those who arrived after
by telling them if they notice anything
different especially over the last few
weeks the question here is what happened
in those last few weeks when she returns
to the glade she finds the drone and
realizes that somehow it's been repaired
when she activates it she hears the dog
creature and notices that it's watching
her then out of nowhere the mother bird
returns and it's just taking care of its
babies again this leads cara to come to
the conclusion that the dogs fixed her
that they fix things and she gets
excited and runs home all of her
problems are solved you do notice that
there's more than one dog when she runs
off and when you get a closer look at
the mother bird it's clear that it's
been altered in some way at home she's
excited to tell her parents about what
happened but she never gets a chance
because she finds out that her brother
zan was killed in an accident which we
don't get any details about here because
the sequence ends with the family
looking at his little body laying there
on the couch
the united fleet of the united nations
of earth and luna and the martian
congressional republic have arrived on
series to their surprise it appears that
marco and the free navy have abandoned
the station sandrine carino makes her
first appearance since season 3 and says
it feels like a trap and avasarala adds
that they're already in it their forces
enter and initially see no one in the
dock area eventually they locate people
who are all grouped together and nico
sandrani says that they are the chief
administrator and they'll talk to
someone who matters they worked for
anderson dawes who avasarala does
consider reasonable so why are they now
working for the man that assassinated
him in response sandrani says i work for
the belt and you know that on some level
abasara understands this she asked why
would marco give up ceres with no
resistance it's crucial for his supply
lines it's the seat of his government it
gives the inners a forward position in
the belt and sandrani doesn't have
answers other than to say that they'll
encounter no resistance on the station
we also learned that staying was a
choice and we learned that the free navy
stripped everything useful from the
station on their way out and at the
current rate of consumption there's only
enough food and air for about three more
weeks this is bad news for the unified
fleet because they have problems at home
that they're having trouble dealing with
and now there are a million people here
that will starve if they don't do
something about it they don't really
have a solution to this in the amount of
time they have to make it happen we saw
at the end of last episode that marco
knew that they would want series and he
took the opportunity to turn it into a
trap he made the mess theirs and if they
don't solve it they'll be responsible
for a major humanitarian crisis at the
same time he gambled with every belter's
life in the station and we learn how he
justifies that over on the pella where
we see that philip is watching news
feeds that are critical of the free navy
and how they left it behind
on the deck rosenfeld is worried about
the inner's response and the number of
ships that they've been able to mobilize
marco brushes it off saying that this is
not the inner's kind of fight the free
navy will hit and run and hit and run
and philip interrupts their conversation
and asked to speak to his father he's
upset that they're being called cowards
and brings up the fact that they did lie
to the people on series marcos says that
they never would have been able to hold
the station against the inners but he
needed the people there to believe that
they could he told them what they needed
to hear and philip actually raises his
voice when he talks about stripping the
station and leaving them without enough
supplies to survive marco takes it to
the next level and starts shouting that
they left a problem for the inners to
deal with they would be forced to tie up
their resources and it will weaken them
he can see that his son is having a hard
time processing it all and says that it
speaks well of him that he's able to
have that feeling of care but then he
makes the distinction that the belters
on series are different he basically
calls them soft saying they're dependent
on their comforts and i think here you
can see where marco's real strengths lie
when he tells his son you and i were
meant to be out here in the darkness in
the fight that's who we are who we were
born to be never forget what your name
is the name we share he gives a son a
hug and the whole thing seems to win him
over for the time being and it makes you
think about that conversation where
drummer and walker were talking where
they both had agreed that he's good at
getting people to follow him in an
episode where so much happens they still
managed to deliver some great character
moments on the rossi which after the
mission for the azeroth dragon is on
route to series holden needs sleep so he
tells clarissa to take over the watch
which surprises her she doesn't really
think she's up for it but he assures her
that the ship basically flies itself in
this situation she just needs to stay
awake in case of an emergency after she
agrees when she stands up she almost
falls over and that leads to a
conversation about her mods she tells
them she got them because of him at
first she just wanted to kill him but
then she decided that disgracing him
would be better maybe it would make her
father look like a hero and she
confesses that she killed bren back in
season 3 episode 7 after he discovered
her bomb on the song yoon each time she
uses them she's reminded of his face in
his last moments and where it gets good
is when holden tries to comfort her by
saying everyone on this ship has
something they regret including amos i
think you're in good company and it's a
great reminder of who this crew is and
why we love them so much we also get a
good back and forth between bobby and
amos who start out talking about how bad
the food is they got for the ship and
when he mentions that ceres has good
noodle shops he mentions working on the
canterbury and they both remarked that
they hadn't thought about the cant for a
very long time they continue this trend
of sort of feeling each other out and
lightly testing each other and we see a
little more of that in the x-ray mini
episode in their quarters naomi's
watching a news feed where one pundit
says it's a win that they've regained
control of series but on the other side
they question how much of our food is
going to support these belter terrorists
holden comes in and wants to talk about
something she gives him permission and
he acknowledges that he didn't want to
push things but he is worried about what
happened during the mission she explains
that she had flashbacks to the pellet
and the chatsumoka and her body just
wouldn't move she thinks she would have
been all right if she just would have
had a little more time but by then
clarissa had taken her place and she
feels humiliated he asks her for a favor
to change the subject and brings up the
bar keith going missing he also tells
her about the data that he got from
bobby about the other missing ships and
she figures out what he's doing she says
you're trying to distract me by giving
me an interesting problem and breaks out
with a big smile because of course
that's what he's doing amos and bobby
continue their bonding ritual working on
her power armor and he gets a message
from prax and i love that she called him
the plant guy so this is another big
character return and maybe he did this
from his closet during the pandemic i'm
not sure but i'm just glad that he's
back we had seen a blurb on the news
about a scientist getting killed on
ganymede when philip was looking at his
hand terminal it turns out that it was
someone prax worked with and they had
discovered a new strain of yeast that
could create massive amounts of food out
of little more than spare carbon dioxide
and waste energy this is one of the many
advancements scientists have made
post-proto-molecule he reached out to
amos because he knows he has connections
and he wanted him to get the data to
somebody important because earth could
really use it to help feed its people he
says don't worry about me or may or the
rest of us i can take care of them and
then he just straight up starts cutting
onions when he says i miss you my friend
amos takes it in and he realizes that
there's absolutely nothing in this for
him that he's really doing this just
because he's a good guy
while holden is finally sleeping naomi
is looking at the missing ship data and
she thinks she notices a pattern she
explains it to him as it's like a hole
opens up in the floor and if someone
falls in then they're gone but then a
minute later the hole itself is gone and
everything seems normal until another
hole opens up somewhere else and then
for the next minute more people fall
into that based on the data she has she
can't say for sure that it's the same
thing that happened to the bar keith and
for now they leave it there on series
monica is out and about filming and
after we see one of the soldiers is
trying to communicate using lang belta
she catches a different un soldier
saying didn't we come here to shoot
these people later she approaches a
belter man who's holding a kitten and we
see that there is a series of explosions
in and around the docks and we don't
really see what set them off or how much
damage they'll cause over on the tynan
drummer and walker are discussing the
golden bow dissidents that they're
teaming up with and it's funny because
she says and you trust them fully to
which he responds fully more like enough
we get another big character return from
the news feeds michio's watching one
where pastor anna is talking about how
people on earth need to work together in
these tough times later in the episode
we find out this is part of monica's
project that avasarala wanted her to do
and joseph comes over and delivers the
line poor poor earther doesn't know
where she'll get her food and water
welcome to the belt drummer gets more
information about the supply depots from
walker there may be up to 10 of them he
thinks and she asks why does he need
them when he has control of all the main
stations he says maybe as a hedge you
know for when the inners came which they
obviously did and then they get
interrupted as michio and joseph get
into a heated discussion about what's
happening on earth you hear joseph say
maybe now they understand and michio
respond that we killed their children
the way they kill ours and you gotta
love how walker's response to this is
that i can see why you didn't want that
one on your ship the two new ships check
in saying we were golden bound now we
fight for you and drummer responds good
i'm ready for a fight and speaking of a
fight we do get a major battle in space
the pela has discovered the rossi on its
way to series marco wants to make a move
and feels confident because they have
them outgunned and it's three ships to
one rosenfeld tries to talk him out of
it because in the big picture the
rossi's not really important and it's
not the right time to take this kind of
risk while they're going back and forth
we can see that philip looks conflicted
but marco orders everyone to their
battle stations and then he tells philip
to take the guns he accepts the order
knowing full well that they are planning
on killing his mother's ship with her in
it they start to close in and the pella
gets a missile lock marco tells philip
to take the shot they fire a group of
missiles that the rossi is able to shoot
down with his pdcs holden gets an idea
to fire up the railgun even though
they're too far away to actually aim it
properly he does a quick turn and fires
a shot that just goes straight in their
direction and it hits the lobber who
didn't have time to react its venting
atmosphere and crippled which takes it
out of the fight and the granicus has to
break off to help them marco says they
don't need either of them they can take
them out themselves and he orders his
crew to maintain distance and watch out
when they flip to fire the railgun he
tells his son to end this now they fire
more torpedoes and they are able to
dodge the railgun shot whenever they see
the rossi turn as things continue the
rossi takes damage with some of their
pdc's misfiring when amos gets up to
repair them clarissa says we're gonna do
that during the fight and he tells her
that's the job peaches and as they move
around they have to brace themselves
every time they turn to fire the railgun
bobby comes up to take over the weapons
and to assess the situation and she
notices when holden fires again that the
pellet dodges the shot in the exact same
way each time she tells holden to fire
some torpedoes that will give them
something different to worry about and
to hand over manual pdc control to her
when he fires the torpedoes she fires a
burst of pdc rounds to where they'll be
at when they dodge the railgun again you
see them moving through space looking
almost like a misfire since they were
aimed at nothing but when they dodge
again they fly right into them and the
pellet gets knocked out temporarily
bobby is ready to take the kill shot and
end the free navy's reign but holden
wants to try to take marco prisoner
naomi jumps in and says that he'll never
surrender which makes holden agree that
if it doesn't work then bobby can take
the shot when he pulls up the comms and
asks marco to give up which of course he
doesn't do knowing that they can see him
on the camera he moves aside so they can
see phillip naomi's baby boy sitting
right there behind him in what he
expects to be his final moments he says
i will die before i live at the end of
your leash and bobby takes the shot
everyone including naomi watches them on
their screens as the torpedo approaches
to end them it hits the ship but the
warhead doesn't detonate and shortly
after that the pellets drive comes back
online they disengage on marco's command
and leave we saw that holden was doing
something as the torpedo was approaching
and we get a shot of his heads up
display where we learned that he
disarmed a torpedo and let them live
they were seconds away from ending the
war and holden couldn't go through with
it on the pela marco is furious that
they lost and he tells philip he failed
in front of everyone philip turns it
around and says that this is actually
his fault because they didn't need to go
after the rossi in the first place he
blames it on marco's pride and
challenges his authority in front of the
whole crew marco calls him a coward cuts
him off and relieves him of duty you see
marco leave and this whole situation is
a big unforced error philip was
basically correct in what he was saying
and rosenfeld had told marco the same
thing even though they survived things
look pretty bad for him and then he gets
a message from medina station someone
there says that medina station is
pleased to report that the
rsrg6 was just received at the laconia
ringgate operational testing will
commence as soon as possible and we will
of course keep you fully apprised if
this one performs as well as the others
it will be fun so this ties into what
they were talking about earlier when
they mentioned that they were installing
something from laconia you get a look at
it moving through the ring but i'm not
sure you can figure it out if you
haven't read the books i will say though
that the letters rsrg 6 are probably a
clue and if you look at how they changed
the opening credits week to week you
might be able to put it together it's
all there to show that marco has
something up his sleeve and the episode
ends there so a really great episode
with just so much going on i'll probably
get tired of saying this by the end of
the season but it really does have
something for everyone mystery on
laconia great character stuff on the
rossi a lot of interesting situations
that people find themselves in this time
of war and a great battle to top it all
off it was nice to see carino anna and
prax and if you think about what we've
seen so far between the crew it doesn't
seem like holden's decision is gonna go
over too well even though they don't
have a lot of time to linger on things
outside of the main character since
there's so much momentum in the
escalating conflict i think they're
doing a great job of showing how this is
affecting regular people across the
board through the news feeds and the
various discussions between characters
people have complicated feelings about
what's happening and then you have the
integration of clarissa into the crew
holding in naomi's private moments i'm
sure everyone's going to be talking
about bobby and amos and their back and
forth and the family dynamics involved
with the pella versus the rossi marco
almost looked like he took pleasure in
ordering his son to kill his mother and
then he wanted him on screen when naomi
had to make the decision to tell bobby
to fire on them just heavy stuff so
there is just so much more to talk about
here so i'm gonna try to do the live
stream again where i can dig a little
deeper hopefully we'll get that process
down over the next couple of episodes i
think i'll leave this one here so let me
know in the comments what you thought
about the episode what you want to get
into when we talk about it some more how
you think things will play out and what
you're hoping to see please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon